When you look at this, what do you see?
To me,
this is one of the most beautiful, fascinating
and frustrating things i've ever seen.
That's
because I'm a mathematician, and these hypnotizing curly cues have haunted people like me for 150
years.
What we're looking at is a glimpse of the Riemann hypothesis.
It's one of the most important
-- if not THE most important -- unsolved problems in all of mathematics.
You may have heard about
the Riemann hypothesis, because it's one of the millennium problems of the Clay Institute.
What
that means is that the person who solves it not only achieves immortality in mathematics,
but
also wins a 1 million prize.
But there are other reasons to care about the enigma that is the
Riemann hypothesis.
If the hypothesis is true, it would solve a mystery as old as math itself:
That is, the mystery of the prime numbers.
Countless theorems in fields as far apart as
cryptography and quantum physics assume that
the Riemann hypothesis is true,
which means that
we have a lot riding on this single, unproven statement.
So, what is it? What is the Riemann
hypothesis?
Why has the search for a proof become something of a holy grail for mathematicians?
And what do these strange curly cues have to do with all of this?
My name is Alex Kontorovich, and
I'm a professor of mathematics.
I'll serve as your guide as we explore the Riemann hypothesis.
In order to build a somewhat sophisticated understanding of this hypothesis,
what I'm going
to try to do is mention some slightly advanced concepts.
Now, you don't need an advanced degree
in mathematics to go on this journey with me.
What I'm going to do is try to lay the groundwork,
step by step, in a visual and intuitive way.
So to begin, let's venture into the chaotic
and elusive universe of prime numbers.
This is factor city, where the primes are
literally the building blocks of all numbers.
Now, every whole number is a building, and it's
been constructed out of its primes.
The one-story houses are exactly the primes.
Now thanks to the
ancient Greek Euclid of Alexandria,
we know that the one-story buildings keep going on forever
-- if you can walk that far.
But, depending on where you're standing, you might want to know:
How
many one story buildings do you see around you?
This is what we want to understand about the prime
numbers, and what we currently don't.
You see, the prime numbers seem to just pop up randomly among
the natural numbers,
all the way out to infinity.
In the late 1700s, mathematicians were
really starting to wonder whether it was
possible to predict the places where primes would
appear.
Now, a teenage boy named Carl Friedrich Gauss
was especially obsessed with taming the
primes.
He calculated massive tables of primes,
going all the way up to 3 million, and looked for
patterns.
We can see the data that Gauss collected on the prime numbers by using something
we'll call the Prime Counting Function.
The graph of that function will show us exactly
where the prime numbers appear as the numbers get
bigger and bigger. So, the graph stays flat until
you hit a prime, and at that point it jumps up byone.
Here's what the graph looks like out to 10
-- and out to 100 --
and now out to 3 million, as far as Gauss went.
At this scale, those
bumps we saw early on have smoothed out,
leaving a pretty pleasant curve.
When Gauss
looked at this data, he asked himself:
Is there some other function that I know that
has pretty much the same graph?
Now, as luck would have it, at around the same time Gauss was
also playing around with logarithm functions.
You might remember that a logarithm is
a function that undoes exponentiation,
much in the same way as division undoes
multiplication.
What Gauss noticed was that the graph of something called the logarithmic
integral function
(that's a function whose slope is 1 over log x)
looked suspiciously similar
to the graph of the Prime Counting Function.
Here's what they look like together.
You can see
why Gauss made the connection.
At this scale, they're so close you can't even distinguish
them.
To understand what the slope of one over log x has to do with prime numbers,
let's pay
another visit to Factor City.
What Gauss imagined was that if you're standing at address x,
and
you look left and you look right,
the proportion of one story buildings, that is primes, that
you would see around you
is roughly the same as one over log x.
This suspicion became known as
Gauss's Conjecture.
After Gauss formulated this conjecture, his student Bernard Riemann went on to
do something absolutely incredible with it.
But to understand what Riemann did, we first have to go
back in time a little bit to meet someone else.
This is Leonard Euler one of the world's first
students of calculus.
Later on in his life, he wrote many influential textbooks
and standardized
the modern math notation that we still use to thisday.
If you've ever written something in standard
function notation -- you know, like y equals f x --
well you can thank, or perhaps blame, Leonard
Euler.
In Euler's time, mathematicians were trying
to understand the general structure of infinite
series.
What that means is you're trying to add up an infinite sequence of numbers, like
1, a
half, a quarter, an eighth, and so on, forever,
sometimes that total sum is a finite number, which
we then call a limit.
If a series has a limit we would say that the series itself is convergent.
In this series, our limit is 2.
On the other hand, if we were to add, let's say, one plus one plus
one plus one plus one forever,
well that sum would eventually become larger than any finite number,
and so we would say that that series is divergent.
Sometimes it can be rather tricky to
tell if a given series converges or not.
So for example, this series, which
is called the harmonic series,
turns out actually diverges, even though the
terms themselves are getting smaller and smaller.
This is really rather not obvious, and takes
some mathematical gymnastics to verify.
Now, what about this series, the sum of 1 over the
squares of all the positive integers?
It wasn't hard for mathematicians to show that this series
does indeed converge.
But the question was, what is the exact limit?
Euler shot to mathematical
superstardom when he saw this problem.
What he realized and proved is that the limit is
pi squared over six.
Isn't that weird? What in the world does pi have to do with the squares?
Well, that's another story for another time.
So, full of adrenaline from his early victory,
Euler kept going.
He found the limits of the sum of one over the positive integers to
the fourth power,
and to the sixth power, and to the eighth power.
Now, let's try to study
all these series at once.
Let's write "s" for that exponent.
When we do this, we define what's called
the Zeta function.
In other words, Zeta of two is the sum of one over the squares,
and Zeta four is
the sum of one over the fourth powers, and so on.
Euler proved that all of these converge, but
only when s is greater than one.
But here's where things got really interesting.
Euler
discovered that the Zeta function could be expressed as an infinite product one -- for
each prime number --
of an infinite series.
Here's what you do:
For each prime number, you add
up one over all the powers of that prime to the s.
If you multiply all those series over all
the prime numbers, you get the Zeta function.
Euler's discovery hinted at an intimate
connection between the Zeta function andprime numbers.
But it would take another hundred
years for the full meaning to reveal itself.
And that's when our friend Bernhard Riemann would
make a major breakthrough in prime number theory.
And that breakthrough would potentially
allow us, for the first time,
to understand the profound mysteries of
prime numbers.
So, Riemann.
He's born in 1826 in modern-day Germany.
He's an absolutely
spectacular and innovative prolific mathematician,
and, among other things, his novel approach to
geometry actually lays the mathematical groundwork for Einstein's theory of relativity.
Riemann was
also one of the founders of complex analysis,
which is a branch of math that studies functions
with complex inputs and outputs.
And he realized he might have something new to say if he studied,
from that point of view, Euler's Zeta function.
You might remember that the square of any
real number is positive:
So 2 squared is 4, but negative 2 squared is also four.
So there
is no number whose square is negative one.
It turns out that it's really rather useful for
mathematicians to have a number whose square is negative one.
So what did we do?
We just
made one up.
We called it "I" for imaginary,
so whenever you see i squared what that means is
you should replace it with negative 1.
This means that any real multiple of i, like 3i or 2i, these
are all imaginary cousins of the real numbers.
When you take combinations of real numbers and
imaginary numbers, you get something we call a
complex number. Complex numbers might look
like two numbers, but they're actually just
one number expressed as two parts: The real part
and the imaginary.
The thing is, these imaginary and complex numbers they aren't imaginary at
all --
they're just the natural extension of our usual number system from one dimension to two.
They're plotted in what we call the complex plane, with the real part going left to right,
and the imaginary part up to down.
Once you have these complex numbers, you can
study complex functions --
that is, functions with inputs and outputs living in the complex plane.
And so, armed with the power of complex analysis,
Riemann opened up a whole new perspective on
the world of mathematics.
Riemann wondered: What would happen if you allowed the Zeta
function to take complex inputs?
That is, he allowed s to be a complex number.
So let's
take the complex exponent s equals two plus 3i, for example.
We can plug it into Zeta
and the
function will look like this.
Now, if we add each term, one at a time in the complex plane,
we can
see how the series begins to spiral beautifully.
So Riemann had successfully accomplished what he
set out to do:
He extended the Zeta function to the complex plane.
But just like Euler, Riemann
found that the function only converged when the real part of s was greater than one.
Now Riemann
had a brilliant idea: He realized it was possible to extend the Zeta function to the rest of the
complex plane.
Riemann used a technique called analytic continuation,
which allowed him to break
open the hidden potential of the Zeta function.
Now, analytic continuation is an advanced concept
in complex analysis,
but it's possible to make sense of it intuitively.
You can think of it as
a logical problem-solving method to extend the domain of a function.
In order for Riemann to fill
in the missing part of the domain in Euler's data function,
he had to create a brand new function.
This function would take the same values as the Zeta function, where they both converge,
but it
had to make sense everywhere else on the plane, too.
So the secret to analytic continuation is
that there are really two functions at work at once.
One is the original Zeta function, which has
limited scope.
But the other is this new function,
the Riemann Zeta function, which extends
beyond the domain that Euler defined.
Remember this?
Now we can take a closer look at
it and finally begin to understand its mysteries.
You see, when Riemann extended the domain of the
Zeta function,
something kind of amazing happened.
In the new territory that Riemann uncovered,
suddenly the Zeta function can be seen crossing through the origin.
What that means is for some
inputs, the Zeta function evaluates to zero.
We call these places the "Zetas zeros".
Some of
the Zeta zeros are easy to explain.
When you input a negative even integer, the Zeta function
equals zero.
But we don't need to worry about these so-called "trivial zeros" -- it's the
non-trivial zeros that we need to talk about.
These other Zeta zeros exhibit a very compelling
pattern,
and that pattern is the central theme of the Riemann hypothesis.
All of the non-trivial
zeros lie inside a single region called the critical strip.
This is where the real part of s
is between 0 and 1.
Riemann proved that there are infinitely many zeros to be found in this critical
strip.
But here is the most important takeaway from Riemann's groundbreaking 1859 paper:
Riemann
hypothesized that all of the non-trivial zeros will lie not just somewhere in the strip,
but
on a single vertical line,
smack dab in the middle.
We call this the "critical line" which
is where the real part of s is exactly one half.
This is exactly the hypothesis that now bears
Riemann's name and the million dollar bounty.
Now at this point, you might be wondering:
Why does the location of these non-trivial
zeros matter, and what does all of this have
to do with prime numbers?
I don't blame you.
Let me show you exactly why Riemann's hypothesis
is of such profound consequence to number theory.
And let me do so by sharing
Riemann's final discovery.
Remember Gauss's prime counting function, from the
very beginning of the video?
Well, for technical reasons we're going to slightly modify it right
now,
but don't worry. We'll preserve the essence of the function.
instead of stepping up by 1 every
time we see a new prime number,
which we'll call p, let us step up by log p.
And we'll also do the
same when we encounter p squared, and p cubed, and p to the fourth, and so on.
So let me
try to explain why we're doing all of this.
Riemann found a surprising connection between
this modification of Gauss's conjecture and his new Zeta function.
He discovered a wave that
corresponds to the Zeta function at s equals one,
and showed that Gauss's conjecture would follow,
if only you could show that this wave was the fundamental frequency,
which means that it more
and more closely approximates the prime counting function as they both grow to infinity.
So here's
what the prime counting function looks like with that wave that Riemann discovered.
Riemann
realized that the Zeta zeros were exactly what he needed to adjust this straight line
to match the
jagged counting function.
Every time he added a Zeta zero, it contributed a harmonic.
Here's what
the first harmonic looks like when we add it on.
It ever so gently tries to smooth out the
wiggles of the modified prime counting function.
what happens when we plug in the
second Zeta zero? Little better, right?
What about the first 10, or the first
30, or the first 60? You get the point.
Riemann was able to rigorously prove that if
you add up all the harmonics of the Zeta zeros,
all infinitely many of them,
you get a perfect
match to Gauss's modified prime counting function.
So, Riemann's hypothesis showed that the
distribution of prime numbers can in fact
be predicted.
The location of prime numbers is
profoundly connected to the location of these non-trivial Zeta zeros.
This means that if the
Riemann hypothesis is indeed true,
it would tell us everything we could possibly have a right to
know about the distribution of prime numbers.
Needless to say, Riemann was unable to
prove the full hypothesis.
In other words, neither he nor anyone since has been able to show
that every single non-trivial Zeta zero
lies on that critical line.
At one point, a massive
computing project checked over one billion non-trivial Zeta zeros
every single day.
The computer was looking for a single errant zero.
If it found just one, then the Riemann
hypothesis would fall apart.
In the end, of the 10 trillion zeros that the computer checked,
every single one was on the critical line.
But if you see a pattern holding again and
again and again,
it's still impossible for machines to check it all the way to infinity.
So
brute force computation will never resolve the Riemann hypothesis.
That means there's
still only one way to be sure of it,
and it's the same way that the ancient Greeks did
their math:
rigorous absolute mathematical proof.